[Musique]
agnès bonjour alors le ministre de
l'éducation jean michel blanquer a
déclaré ne pas prévoir de retour en
classe avant le 4 e mail back pourrait
débuter le 17 juin comme prévu
est ce que c'est une sage décision
écoutez jeu honnêtement je ne sais pas
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que dire qu'il
y a une vraie continuité pédagogique
c'est absolument pas le cas parce que
faire du travail à distance en utilisant
les outils numériques ne remplacera
jamais un enseignant donc est ce que
jean michel blanc coeur estime qu'il
faut modifier le baccalauréat le brevet
est ce que ça va se maintenir est ce que
je sais pas mais en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que cette organisation de
continuité pédagogique n'est absolument
pas correct dans la manière dont elle
est mise en place
c'est à dire que nous nous avons été mis
sur le fait accompli
jeudi soir là on a appris la fermeture
des écoles exactement maintenant tous
les français donc c'est à dire qu'on n'a
pas eu le temps de se concerter entre
nous on n'a pas eu le temps d'organiser
quoi que ce soit donc on s'est retrouvé
à s'auto s'autoformer entre nous pour
pouvoir utiliser les espaces de
numérique de travail
on a dû voilà ceux utilisés notre propre
matériel c'est dire que l'éducation
nationale ne nous a pas fourni
d'ordinateurs de téléphones donc on
utilise notre propre matériel dont
clairement cette situation n'est pas
bonne du tout ni pour les enseignants ni
pour les élèves alors justement
justement le vote quotidien à titre
personnel votre quotidien de professeurs
est ce que vous êtes en relation avec le
ministère du gouvernement avec les
élèves les parents
est-ce que vous avez des retours de vote
de vos collègues oui bien sûr je parle
beaucoup avec kiel avec nikola on a des
coupes what's up du ministère objets pas
de nouvelles voilà je pense que c'est
pareil pour tout le monde
non non on n'a aucune directive donc on
se débrouille donc du coup ce qui ce qui
entraîne un
un grand cafouillage parce que on
n'utilise pas forcément tous les mêmes
systèmes pour contacter nos élèves c'est
un peu comme on peut c'est à dire que
certains vont utiliser des des espaces
numériques tels que classroom pronote
certains vont les appeler certainement
faire ddd vision des classes en visio et
du coup les élèves se retrouvent noyés
dans sept 7
cet énorme informations qu'il y a et du
coup bah c'est vrai que c'est un petit
peu compliqué la première semaine
évidemment pas tous les tous les élèves
de france se sont connectés en même
temps notamment après note donc ça ça
crée forcément des bugs ça ne
fonctionnait pas
le site est en maintenance donc on a
essayé de les contacter autrement par
paroisse de ça par téléphone
armelle et comme on a su le jeudi soir
que tout allait fermer bien évidemment
là elle tente d'anticiper de demander
tout bien tous les mails aux parents de
bien récupérer tous les numéros de
téléphone donc c'est vraiment très
compliqué jean blanc caire dit qu'aucun
élève ne sera laissé sur le bord du
chemin c'est chaud c'est totalement faux
parce que justement justement vous à
titre personnel vous occuper un des
élèves handicapés
qu'en est il des élèves atteints d'un
handicap aucune structure ne semble
avoir été mise en place
faut-il tirer la sonnette d'alarmé oui
alors justement notamment les élèves en
situation de handicap c'est une
catastrophe parce que c'est des élèves
qui ont besoin d'un accompagnement
adapté avec un étayage avec un
enseignant spécialisé avec des voiles à
adapter son mode de travail faire des
manipulations faire et c'est évident que
les parents de ne peuvent pas le faire
parce qu'ils ne sont pas des enseignants
et encore moins spécialisés donc c'est
très difficile ce sont des enfants qui
peuvent avoir des troubles du
comportement donc il faut quand même se
dire que les familles se retrouvent
seuls à 24 heures sur 24 avec ses
enfants qui n'ont plus accès aux soins
et donc c'est très compliqué mais il
n'ya pas que les élèves en situation de
handicap qui vont se retrouver sur le
bord du chemin c'est à dire que toutes
les familles précaires qui n'ont
accès au numérique qui n'ont pas accès à
internet
les familles qui n'ont pas juste le
bagage scolaire pour accompagner leurs
enfants les familles qui sont en
télétravail qui ont un ordinateur pour
toute la famille qui ont peut-être deux
trois enfants avec des niveaux scolaires
différents
c'est totalement ingérable donc oui il y
aura des élèves qui vont être laissé au
bord du chemin malheureusement et dire
que c'est de la continuité pédagogique
c'est faux ce n'est pas vrai ça n'a pas
du tout le même impact que d'aider des
élèves devant devant des professeurs
donc il faut arrêter de dire continuité
pédagogique c'est pas vrai on essaye de
sauver un peu les meubles de cette
situation sanitaire inédite
merci beaucoup à niasse à jafar un belgo
belge professeurs des écoles pour
enfants en situation
oui je peux juste rajouter un district
vous écoutez je rappelais de rapidement
rapidement du très rapide on a en fait
de la situation de l'accueil des enfants
de soignants dans les écoles donc
c'était juste pour dire que c'était
quand même assez compliqué parce que les
enseignants qui font ça a volontairement
non absolument pas de protection n'ont
pas de masque n'ont pas de gants n'ont
pas de gel ils ont dû m'entendez oui oui
voilà les élèves quand il est rapidement
s'auto-organiser il n'y a aucune
directive ni du rectorat ni du ministère
donc tous ces faits à l'intérieur des
écoles ils n'ont reçu des protections
que le jeudi c'est à dire masques gants
et gèle et ce week end
tout ce matériel a été réquisitionnée
retour à l'envoyeur pour retourner dans
les hôpitaux c'est à dire que ces
enseignants se retrouvent dans des
écoles avec des enfants sans protections
et c c'est parfaitement inadmissible la
circulation crise sanitaire on l'avait
compris la gravité de la situation merci
beaucoup
anja jafar d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur pour enfants en situation
d'handicap à paris au collège
alain-fournier